[Music]
but today is games you should know by
heart so I'm going to walk you guys
through
probably I would say 8 to 10 Miniatures
that
um maybe you can memorize uh most games
I'll show are under 20 moves and these
are mostly that I have memorized that
I've shown to students over the years
and um I think they're they're not only
like fun to look at but also um very
instructive and a lot of them come with
like opening ideas that uh that can be
very
venomous I don't have coffee on my face
do I no no okay i' I've been drinking
this a lot
okay okay I would like to start out with
kind of a a fun one um it's Poss you've
seen some of these
before um I've called this how to beat
Mike Hummer as if we know Mike Hummer's
favorite opening
anyone Simon fried liver yeah so I'm
going to show a response to the fried
liver for black and don't tell Mike cmer
about this cuz if you ever play him he
might uh he might walk into it so the
game goes E4 E5 Knight F3 Knight C6 and
we'll go into a standard fried
liver and I have to say I've had this
exact same game at least three times in
online Blitz and few more times just
over the board play um in casual games
and I know if you play against mikomer
he'll get very very excited after Knight
G5 uh threatening F7 and I know he's
he's won a lot of games as whites um so
the main move for black is
D5 uh simply defending against Knight or
Bishop take
F7 uh Mike will almost always take on
D5 and now black has a um a few
different moves here but the the most
ven venomous move and the move that I
would play um especially if I'm looking
to to win quickly is Knight
D4 and I'm not actually sure if Mike has
seen this line before but if he hasn't
um it's very very tempting for white to
play
D6 and a lot of players will play D6
without thinking too much with the idea
of discovered attack against F Pawn
threatening either Bishop take F7 or
Knight take
F7 now the nice thing about this
position for black is you don't have to
defend against the F7 threat you can
simply create counterplay of your own so
best move is Queen take
D6 and okay if uh if Mike cmer were
playing white he would probably take
with the Knight he would see the the
queen attacked Rooks attacked he'll uh
he'll win The Rook on
h8 um black will play Queen
C6 um attacking the bishop attacking the
pawn um let's say white ignores both of
those threats takes a
rook uh let me ask you guys would you
take the bishop on C4 or the pawn on
G2 assuming you haven't seen the
notation
C2 you mean G2 or
C4 oh yeah G2 G2 yeah um yeah amazingly
Queen takes G2 is much stronger than
Queen takes C4 um usually you want to
take the more valuable piece but in this
position taking on G2 and opening the
king side is going to lead to to much
better things for black um so now
Black's attacking The Rook Rook has to
move to F1 to save
itself and now there's a pretty nice
finish uh I'll show you guys the first
move Queen
E4 let's say Bishop
E2 black to move beat
mycer Ben Simon sees it what is it
knight3 Knight F3 mate
pretty nice way smother mating the the
white king um a lot of people will just
walk into this unknowingly um as white
if we look at White's moves they were
pretty much all natural um starting with
Pawn take on D5 D6 sorry D6 was uh the
most logical move threatening the pawn
and
um if white gets greedy wins material he
gets severely
punished
so you can trap a lot of beginners in
this line but um amazingly this line has
also been played
against one of the top players of all
time so if we go
back uh to this
position um I don't know if uh if too
many people know about this game but
there was a game Bobby fiser lost in
under 15 moves and he also had this
position as white and black played the
same line
D5 Pawn take 5 Knight
D4 and I should mention that fer was
playing an A simal so usually um during
a simal you might not be thinking that
straight and in this game I think he he
got a little too confident and then fell
apart very quickly so the move he played
here is actually the best move for sure
played C3 in this position much stronger
than D6 simply attacking the Knight and
kind of putting the question where does
the knight move um
now Fisher's opponent uh whose name was
actually Robert berer which maybe sounds
slightly appetizing Robert did not move
the Knight on D4 but he counterattacked
he played B5 which is a very standard
move for this position um creating a lot
of chaos Knight's attacked but the
bishop is also attacked so if Pawn take
Knight Pawn take Bishop it would get uh
a little bit crazy so Fischer in this
position played the best move and maybe
the not the most obvious move he played
Bishop to
F1 um and I should probably explain this
move it's a little bit complicated but
uh he Retreats all the way back to F1
because he wants to keep an eye on
attacking the B5 pawn and he doesn't
play Bishop E2 because of Knight take
E2 and he doesn't play Bishop
D3 because black has this annoying move
Bishop F5 and the bishop wouldn't be
defended on D3 and um I think this would
be very reasonable for black so after
Bishop
F1 black is now in somewhat of a pickle
because he um his Knight is still
attacked on D4 and the Knight is also
defending the pawn on B5 which is
attacked by the bishop so the move uh
Burger plays in this position is Knight
take D5 winning the pawn on D5 and
attacking the
Knight so black wants to play Queen take
G5 next uh fiser continues Pawn take
Knight Queen take Knight Bishop take B5
with check and now the interesting thing
about this game is black completely
ignored the fact that his King's in the
center and attacks and he simply moved
King
d8 and his main focus was to forget
about his King in the center but to
focus on um on on attacking White's King
and um as we'll see that's uh it's
pretty much how the game ended so fiser
castled black played Bishop to B7 then
Fisher played Queen F3 which no maybe
looks a little bit suspicious at first
because the queen is on the same diagle
as the bishop but any knight move any
discovered attack against the queen
would walk into Queen take B7 so the
Knight is actually pinned to the bishop
and now it's a little bit crazy because
both players are aiming to uh to attack
each other's King uh this position black
played Pawn take on
D4 and then fiser made the losing move
um it's interesting because the losing
move here for white looks like a winning
move anyone want to try and guess what
white
played how can and white win a pawn and
thre mate and
one yeah that's exactly what fiser
played and usually when you play the
same move as fiser it's usually a good
thing but in this case it's a pretty bad
thing um because after Queen take
F7 black responded by not only defending
against the the queen D7 threats but he
made a threat of his own the um the
crushing move for black was played
Knight
F6 and after Knight F6 Fischer
resigned uh there's just too many
threats the most obvious threat Queen
take
G2 the second most obvious threat Queen
bishop
and probably the the easiest to overlook
threat let's say um let's say white
defends and plays
G3 uh black would
play uh pretty much the the soul
crushing Bishop D5 is trapping the
queen and uh the queen has nowhere to go
so that's how you beat Fisher in what
was it 12 moves doesn't happen too often
I think this is the shortest ever
recorded game that fer lost so yeah
definitely a game you should know by
Hearts any game where you beat Fisher in
12 moves you should have memorized so
how about we move on um we moved from
beating Mike Hummer to beating Fisher so
let's uh let's continue trying to walk
up the chain uh next game I want to show
you guys
is how to be kakan in under 15
moves and the the interesting thing
about this game after I saw this game I
started playing the English opening I
started playing C4 on move one because I
saw if karakin can lose in um actually
12 moves against uh against this opening
then might be an opening to consider
playing kaken was defin
the the um kind of the the losing player
in this game so this was a rapid
game uh C4 E5 Knight C3 Knight C6 Knight
F3 and most common move for black here
is to play Knight F6 which is called the
Four Knights English um kaken chose a
slight side variation he played Pawn
G6 which has somewhat of a solid
reputation the idea for black is to play
just Bishop G7
D6 um usually Knight E7 Castle
eventually F5 and if white doesn't
interfere with the setup it it's very
reasonable for black but um in this
position white challenged black
immediately by playing
D4 and definitely the most ambitious
move uh karakan
took and now most logical move is to
take back on D4 but that's not what what
white played white played Knight to
D5 and this is the type of move you
might see more often in a Blitzer rapid
game um which it's sacrificing material
but aiming to attack the opponent as
quickly as possible um so black
continued Bishop
G7 and now white starts with uh with
some initiative Bishop to
G5 and the pieces are coordinating very
well the Knight supports the bishop oop
the bishop attacks the queen Knight on
D5 controls both squares that could help
lock the queen or block the Bishop from
attacking the queen um and of course the
D4 Pawn is also um Under Fire so white
white has act upon Pawn but accelerated
the development of of the pieces so
black play Knight G7 which is not the
best move uh black should have played
probably F6 which is slightly ugly
looking move blocking the bishop but
it's probably necessary um after Knight
G7 white plays a a pretty brilliant move
here um I might as well just show you
guys Knight take
D4 with the main idea
of um of disturbing this knight from
defending E7 so if Knight take
D4 then white would simply win the Queen
Bishop take E7 Queen is trapped
if Bishop take
D4 which was played in the game uh it's
actually even worse for black because
white has amazing Queen take
D4 and let me ask you guys can black
take the
queen what would happen in this position
if black takes the queen on D4 white to
move you can pause your video at
home kn6 check Knight F6 King f8 Bishop
H6 this is a classic mating pattern with
just Knight and Bishop pretty pretty
epic we to finish off a game so karakan
saw
that and he uh you see he's in big
trouble here because um Knight F6 is a
huge threat and he decides to
Castle and amazingly enough it's white
to move Maiden five and I'm not
expecting any of you will it too quickly
so I'll give you the first few moves um
white will play Knight F6
check King
h8 and now maybe the hardest move to
find um White's Queen is still under
attack so any knight move would allow
Queen take or Knight take
D4 however there is a move here to uh to
sacrifice the queen but get mates and
that move is Knight G4
and at this point
karakan had enough he saw that mate was
coming and he resigned um if the game
were to
continue uh black would have to pretty
much take the queen and now it's going
to be the same type of mating pattern
with the bishop and the Knight just
dominating the
king so this was a pretty sweet game um
actually 10 moves uh after Knight G4
black designing so um it's not every day
a super GM loses in uh in 10 moves and
just uh just for the record I should
verify this was andreen and this was
2010 so um I think kakin has learned his
lesson since then let me show you guys a
game that I
played uh this is a game it was just
like a casual bits game that I played
back in
2013 or
2014 and it was after a tournament
finished I was waiting in the hotel
lobby for my cab I was playing my friend
AE and we played a Blitz game which um
which has stuck with me to this day and
right after we played the game I I
remembered all the moves and then
started showing it to all my students
and it's a pretty memorable game for um
for reasons which you'll see so there's
another English opening
and we just saw uh we just saw white
crush with the English now we're going
to see black crushing the English um I
played
E5 a played Knight
C3 and I played
D6 which um it's funny it's actually
kind of similar to the setup that kakin
was trying to use uh my plan is to play
G6 Bishop G7 ight knight7 and just have
a solid position and my opponent
Disturbed it or tried to disturb it as
much as possible he played Pawn to
D4 um attacking the E Pawn and trying to
slow down my development so I took he
took whoop mouth
slip uh I played Knight
C6 and then he played kind of a weird
looking move but it's actually very fine
move he played Queen D2 looks like it
blocks in the bishop but this bishop on
C1 actually wants to go to B2 so d is
actually a very fine Square for the
queen and after B3 Bishop B2 white is
just continuing to have some uh
harmonious
development so at this point um most of
my moves kind of were were played with
some kind of uh overall purpose in mind
um first move is Bishop to E6 attacking
C4 provoking my opponent to play
B3 and then I play Knight to E7
um so what my goal is in this position
is simply to play Pawn D5 so I've
already have three pieces
developed and it's not so common that
black is a head in development over
white so early in the game but because I
have a bit more development I want to
open up the position because usually if
you're head in development um any
opening of the position will will favor
you um so now White made a a pretty slow
and just probably bad move he play
G3 aiming to play Bishop G2 but it's too
slow because I hit him immediately with
D5 so what white should have done was
probably play E4 just control more space
and and stop
D5 but after G3 then black uh black sees
his initiative I play D5 he takes I
take and now if we look there's uh
there's some problems for white the
bishop on f8 is coming to B4 and I have
threats if white isn't careful and plays
Bishop
G2 I have ideas of um oh I was about to
say take take and Bishop B4 but that
probably doesn't work because Bishop
takes
C6
um so I probably would play after Bishop
G2 maybe just Bishop B4 and increase
pressure along this
diagonal um my oppent played a very
suspicious looking move he played Pawn
A3 if we notice white has done very
poorly in uh in developing his pieces
and and giving me a lot of initiative
and this was a Blitz game
and um normally I would play pretty fast
uh especially early on in the Blitz game
but in this position I uh I stopped and
probably thought for at least a minute
cuz there's a line here which I began
calculating
and the calculation kind of flows and it
turns out that in this position before I
played my next move I actually saw what
was going to end the game I saw the
final position um before I played my
next move so I'm not going to have you
guys try and calculate the whole
variation but um but there is a
variation here where if White's not
careful it could just be game over so
let me show you guys uh first few moves
then I'll have you you guys try and find
the final move
so I play Knight takes
C3 he takes I play Queen
D5 so double attack forking the rook and
the pawn white obviously wants to save
The Rook so he plays Knight
F3 um I saw I could win the pawn take
take
take so I was about to play this really
quickly um ahead of time but when I was
calculating this I saw that I'm not
actually winning a that easy because
white can play Rook
B1 skewering the bishop to the B7 pawn
and it looks like white can win the pawn
back um but amazingly enough black has a
pretty uh hidden resource here to uh to
trick white
so having already calculated the move
ahead of time I played my next move very
quickly I played Bishop
A4 he took on
B7 assuming he would just win back the
pawn no problem and now black to move
and finish off the game I played one
more move and then white
resigned Pawn oh Rook d8 Rook d8 yeah um
bit more
aggressive um white wouldn't resign
after this move I know it's threatening
mates but white can play like Bishop D2
defend but you have an idea you have an
idea of threatening mate on
D1 now you want to look for a different
move which might use the same same
mating idea but slightly different
execution okay what are the opening
principles attack the center develop
your
pieces castle castle
yes okay you were
playing yeah Castle Queen side a
accomplishes these two goals um remember
it's it's legal to move your Rook
through attack but not the king through
attack so casting is perfectly legal
here and there's no way white can defend
against mate and Save The
Rook
so pretty nice way to uh to win a Blitz
game unfortunately for my opponent um
nothing he could do but uh but give up
in this position so if we go back um
just to kind of walk you through the
thought proc process of calculating
forward um I I basically just look for
the most natural moves and usually when
I I think in the Blitz game I'll just
kind of play a game out in my head and
then look for kind of most expected
moves for each side so I calculated the
most forcing move I had seen the fork
I'd seen he would probably defend I I
saw I won the pawn I saw we would trade
now I saw Rook B1 and this is where I
spent most of my time thinking how how
do I deal with Rook B1 and then I saw um
this Bishop A4 and Castle Queen side
idea
and uh I should also mention there's
many chess books with this type of
puzzle I I've seen many puzzles like
this where the the solution is castl and
queens side um there's actually a lot of
puzzles where if we just cheat for a
moment where the bishop is not here but
the king's on D1 and you would Castle
Queen side with check and win The Rook
so sometimes exposure to these creative
ideas can actually allow you to to find
them in your own
games so any
questions okay let's do a game um so
this is actually a game of a
former uh wgm in Residence uh Karina
neova and the way I found this game is
by looking up her games and then finding
the shortest decisive game she'd ever
played and this was a game she beat uh I
forget the exact rating but it was
someone over 2,000 and she was black and
she played against the Smith
MOA and it's very rare that you'll see
black win early in the Smith MOA because
it's usually white sacrificing a pawn
for counterplay but we're going to see a
nice opening trick by uh by Katarina so
I'm going to just zoom through the moves
and for anyone who plays with Sicilian
as as black I would highly recommend
looking maybe a bit deeper at this
variation because I think it's um it's
not only nice trick to play but it's
also a very sound variation against the
Smith MOA so white will play D4 sack the
pawn and then black will continue
E6 Knight C6 Bishop
C4 and okay there's a lot of uh lot of
different moves here I know Ben fold
wrote a whole book about the fold system
against Smith MOA I honestly have no
clue what that is but I think it
involves putting the queen on B7 or
something um anyway the move that
Katarina played here is start with Queen
C7 White Castles and then she plays
Knight
F6
and most Smith MOA players will kind of
play in the same fashion um the idea
about the Smith MO is sacrificing the
pawn mainly to open up the defile and to
use uh use some kind of initiative
against uh black Black's dwn and usually
white will play Queen E2 preparing Rook
D1 and here's is where black kind of
sets up the Trap and black plays a very
kind of weird looking move but actually
makes a lot of sense the more you look
at it Knight to
G4 kind of breaking some principles
moving the same piece
twice uh but there's a very sneaky
threat where if white isn't careful
white can lose a game right
away um so I've I've actually had this
exact same position myself and I I've
had a couple games where white plays a
losing move and I'll win instantly so
the losing move here which um I've
encountered and Katarina actually
encountered in in a tournament is
playing
H3 uh terrible move um I've actually
looked this up in the database there's
45 games where white has played this
move loses every single game uh black to
move win the
game Knight D4 very
nice really same thing yeah
like ouch usually what happens happens
if you walk into the strap as as white
you learn it and never happens again um
Knight D4 is pretty painful because
Queen's attacked idea is on H2 if the
queen moves let's say D1 you just remove
the Knight and then made on
H2 the best white can do I think is take
the Knight and then just lose the queen
but most people either resign or get
mated before
this
yep um so yeah pretty it's a pretty
nasty variation um this Knight G4 move
and interesting thing about this is
White's best move here isn't that
obvious um white pretty much has to play
G3 as far as I know um simply blocking
the diagonal and then black would
continue with uh with H5 and have some
um some interesting Dynamic play and
also important important to not Black's
up a pawn so Black's attacking and up a
pawn uh another variation white could
try Rook D1 preventing Knight D4 but
that would allow Bishop to
C5 and then it's very annoying for white
to deal with the pawn on F2 and black is
um just simply better here initiative
extra Pawn white would probably have to
play Bishop to E3 trade off some pieces
if Rook F1 then Knight D4 again
wins
so yeah Sicilian players I mean learning
this line for black against the Smith
MOA is uh is very much worth it uh let
me show you two games which have like a
similar theme but are different openings
uh we're going to start with a French
defense I don't know if I have the game
here but hopefully I know it by heart um
this is a an opening I teach to a lot of
students because it's very venomous
and if black plays naturally uh black
will lose very
quickly
so uh White will play E4 and if you're
an E4 player and you don't know what to
play against the French I would highly
recommend checking out this this opening
um it's called the two knights attack
starts with Knight
F3 black will play D5 and then white
will play Knight
C3 so just named after the fact that
White's developing two knights as
quickly as possible
um so the main line goes Knight
F6 white will play
E5 Knight D7
D4 and one of the points behind the two
Knight's attack is white will aim to
control the center more with the minor
pieces rather than the pawns and white
is completely okay giving up the D4 Pawn
so after the main move C5 white will
just simply take and white is more
concerned about just completing
development playing Bishop Bishop F4 and
Bishop D3 and not concerned about
keeping the D4 Pawn so black will um
usually take back white will play Bishop
D3 let's say Knight
C6 now Bishop
F4 now we've reached a classic position
in the two knights attack and if you
play this opening for white you should
definitely know this position and know
kind of the main black black moves that
black can play here um there are
I would say three common moves that
black plays uh two of them get into
trouble very quickly and then one of
them is just the main line main line is
F6 Pawn take F6 Knight take F6 and it's
a playable position white has given up
both Center pawns but um but has some
nice play with Queen E2 Castle Queen
side maybe Knight E5 and um there's many
uh many GM games which have gone down
this route but the uh the miniature that
I would like to show you is when black
plays the natural but terrible move
castling
kingside walking into a very classic
trick from
whites and especially if you're a French
defense player is black you should know
about this trick and know kind of when
not to walk into it uh White to move and
pretty much win the
game
Ben Simon have you seen this
before I think so what do you think the
move is Bishop take H Bishop take H7 we
call this the Greek
gift um it's very important like
especially when you play chess to kind
of develop some pattern recognition so
when you see your Bishop on D3 Knight on
F3 Queen on D1 and black is Castle of
kingside with the structure you should
instantly think Greek gift and then
calculate to see if it works
um in this case I mean it's pretty much
just Unstoppable after Bishop take H7
king take H7 Knight
G5 I've seen many many games go down
this path uh best move for black is
actually to play King G6 here and try
and weather the storm um but the game
I'll show is King
G8 which uh which just gets smashed by
Queen
H5 and now Black's in a situation where
mate is coming on H7 and there's very
very few ways to defend against mate uh
the best move for black is probably
Queen take G5 which just loses a queen
um a lot of players will try to play
Rook
E8 um and now it's white to move and
made in one two
three four if I'm counting
correctly first move is Queen take
F7 King h8
oh I think it was five moves I wasn't
counting correctly Queen H5 King G8
Queen H7 king f8 queen h8 king E7 Queen
take G7 mate this is all forced since
black played Rook
E8
so this is called the Greek gift um the
Greek gift is Bishop take
H7 but the um the opening is the two
knights attack against the French
defense yeah
um yeah very vamous opening because
black always has to be careful about
castling and usually if you can get
Bishop take H7 it's um it falls apart
very quickly for
Black so yeah if you're going to
memorize uh one line against the French
defense definitely memorize this
line okay let me show you another game
uh related theme but different
opening next game I'm going to show you
deals with this move
B3 has anyone encountered this move on
the black
side I mean yeah the main point of this
move is to like throw throw off the the
opponent and get into some position
without too much opening
Theory now the nice thing if you're
playing Black is to actually know some
Theory and
um and and know what to do and it all
all you have to know is really one line
to play against B3
and it's um it's actually one of my
favorite openings is black if if my
opponent plays B3 I'll uh I'll
automatically play this line so goes E5
Bishop B2 attacking the pawn Knight C6
defending
E3 Knight F6 and most players when they
play B3 on move one they'll go into this
line um the two Bishops coordinate
pretty well the first Bishop attacks
Knight second Bishop pressures the pawn
so white is planning to win a pawn here
white wants to to take on C6 and then
take on
E5 and if you don't know what to do as
black in this position it's actually
sort of annoying because um it's not
that obvious how to defend the pawn on
E5 and you might have to do something
like D6 or Bishop
D6 but the best move is actually a
really nice move for black is to play
E5 simply moving the pawn up a square
and um leaving white without a Target so
now the the bishop is just kind of
staring at uh at the Knight which is
very well supported the pawn is very
safe on D5 it can be protected um at
some point with D5 and in the process
black is just gaining space I should
also mention here that after E4 black
wants to play A6 and just get rid of
this bishop on
B5 so I've had countless games where my
opponent will play Knight E2 I'll play
A6 and now white is forced to trade off
the bishop for the Knight the bishop can
not
Retreat uh I believe to either Square
because D5 just traps the
bishop so white would have to
take
take um and let's say castle Bishop
D6 and I think I've had two online one
minute games where I've reached this
exact position and both games ended the
exact same way and now you guys should
kind of recognize the pattern from what
we just saw you should recognize the
bishop the Knight the queen and this uh
this structure on the king side so what
would the move be for
black Bishop take
H2 uh same pretty much same exact thing
Greek gift um this case I mean not too
much different white will take black
plays Knight
G4 uh so last time we saw the king
retreating to G1 and after Queen H4 it's
it's looking pretty bad um the game I
want to show you now is with King to
G3 um because after King G3 black still
has to play somewhat accurately to win
win the game and black actually has a a
bunch of very goodl looking moves here
um black could play Queen G5 black could
play Queen D6 check black could play
H5 I think all of these move moves give
black some Advantage um but the the move
that I like to play is H5 just wanting
to bring the pawn to H4 and if we look
the king doesn't really have too many
squares the king cannot move
backwards uh and the King does not want
to move on the same diagonal as the
bishop
so uh White is pretty stuck in this
position and both the games I played
that reached this point uh White took on
e4 and now if I'm not mistaken after H4
King
F3 uh black to move and force
mat um I'm just looking for the first
move so what's the strongest check that
black can deliver in this
position very good we call we call it a
rook not a castle but yeah Knight yeah
Knight H2 uh yeah foring the king and
the Rook but more importantly dragging
the king up the board because the king
cannot move to G3 it has to move to
F4 and we're actually not concerned
about winning The Rook we're concerned
about checkmating the king and in this
position the checkm is pretty beautiful
black can play
G5 King E5
and just F6
mate so I've had this exact same
position twice and it's a nice position
because black pretty much is not
developed the only developed piece is a
knight on H2 and the pawns are doing a
good chunk of the
work so this is a pretty nice game to
know by heart if uh especially if you
know that someone's going to play the
Larson opening um a lot of times they
will reach at least position and if you
know to play E4 I think um I think it
guarantees black a very comfortable game
also leads to the possibility of done
locking into the into the the Greek gift
so um any questions so
far anyone heard of Alex yalinsky
yes pretty famous player um given bunch
of lectures online uh also wrote a book
called The Road to chess improvements um
and now he's more of a a coach than a
player um anyone heard of emry Tate yes
okay Ben Simon knows everyone um Emy
Tate is maybe one of the most famous
International Masters that lived in the
US um he passed away a few years ago but
he was known as one of the more
aggressive players out there and I
actually played Tate four times in
tournament games when I was younger and
I've lost every single time I think he's
the only person that I have a zero for a
record against and unfortunately I can't
improve it now that uh he's uh he's gone
but um anyway this is one of Tate's
probably most embarrassing games because
he lost in uh in under 15 moves and
um he he tried to use his his kind of
unique creative and aggressive style but
it pretty severely backfired so yur
molinsky is white yur molinsky is known
for kind of just classical solid Soviet
style chess and we see this on the very
first move uh with D4 and then tap plays
C5 um Tate trying to to throw him off
and get some kind
of weird unique position um usually when
black plays C5 uh the best move is D5
which is what yalinsky played um one of
the ideas is if white takes the pawn
then black would simply play E6 and then
WI back the pawn easily with uh with two
Center pawns against one Center Pawn so
D5 uh especially if you're a D4 player
D5 is certainly the move to play in this
position um but Tate continues
E6 yalinsky defends the pawn with the
Knight Knight C3 take
take and the game actually revolves now
around the D5 Square white has just
complete control over the square uh with
the Knight on D5 support Ed by the queen
and Tay tries to remove the Knight so he
starts with Knight
E7 and now let me ask you guys an
interesting question um how can you use
this bishop to help control the D5
Square as usually a dark squared Bishop
cannot help control a light square but
in a case like this there is a move
which um which
works Bishop G5 Bishop G5 very good so
you're not directly attacking the square
but you are pinning the Knight which was
trying to challenge the square um so
white has some nice pressure against the
Knight has control over D5 Tate plays
H6 trying to kick away the bishop Bishop
H4 and now um Tate did not play the
worst move in the position which is
G5 because that would get smothered
mated instantly with Knight F6
um instead Tate tries a different idea
which is almost just as bad he plays
Queen
A5 which looks okay unpinning the
knights
C3 and then he plays Knight
F5
and looks okay for black uh he's solved
the problem of the pin Queen's active
Knight's active attacking the bishop um
however he missed uh White's next move
and after white White's next move the
game pretty much ends instantly so white
to move and
win Knight F6
check looks risky Pawn
take
and Knight C7 Knight C7 you would love
to play if the queen weren't on A5
it would be made if the queen weren't on
on A5 but just Queen take
right so it's interesting because Knight
C7 um you might see this move first then
you see the Queen's attacking and then
that should kind of lead you to look for
ways to remove this queen from
A5 it's very common you'll see an idea
before you see the actual execution of
the idea so how can you remove the queen
from A5 to make Knight C7 possible
Caleb do you see it you do what is it
Queen
A4 it's completely okay to give away a
queen if you're going to mate and in
this case if the queen is taken I think
emry Tate actually took the queen he saw
he was losing anyway and then just got
mated um yeah pretty unfortunate way to
lose a game and there's no other like
good continuation for black the queen
has to stay defending the square but I
can't move to any of these squares
they're all controlled by the white
pieces um so yeah that's how you be an
IM in what nine moves
so I hope you guys are inspired um hope
hopefully you've learned maybe some new
openings some new tricks that you can
use and thanks for coming
out time for Thai
[Music]
food
[Applause]
[Music]
oh